uh i never lied i took all my teammates
into a huddle and told them trust me i'm
more or less immunized go team
pete davidson played aaron rodgers on
saturday night live following a week of
controversy for the green bay packers
quarterback i find it interesting that
people care enough
about somebody like myself well erin you
might want to get used to that our first
guest is an american brave enough to
stand up and say screw you science i
know joe rogue cicely strong played fox
news host janine pirro alongside pete in
the night's opening sketch
nfl mvp aaron rodgers
hey janine it's great to be here
remember when i hosted jeopardy and the
pair wasted no time poking fun at some
of the comments from the nfl star it's
gotten so bad that state farm called and
they're not even offering me the roger's
braid
rogers came under fire last week after
testing positive for covet 19. are you
vaccinated and what's your stance on
vaccinations yeah i've been immunized
that comment from rogers back in august
led many to believe he had been
vaccinated but in fact he received
homeopathic treatment from his personal
doctor leading to this moment in the
show
did you ever lie about being vaccinated
uh i never lied i took all my teammates
into a huddle got all their faces three
inches away from my wet mouth
and told them trust me i'm more or less
immunized go team
pete also referenced this interview with
rogers following the backlash
i realize i'm in the crosshairs of the
woke mob right now and now he can add
snl to that list it's my body and my
covey you know i can give it to whoever
i want but suddenly the woke mob is
coming after me but at the end of the
day my record is still 7-1
meaning of the eight people i've
infected seven or five plus episode
featured some real stars starting with
host kiernan culkin
i play uh roman rory he's one of the
nicer characters on the show
which still makes him one of the top 10
worst humans on tv
later cast member eggo wodum reprised
her role of music legend dion warwick
and it turned out she has an iconic fan
you know i'm sick and tired of
interviewing people who are not icons
please welcome me
yep the real dion made a surprise
appearance and even serenaded her comedy
counterpart
the
[Music]
later in the broadcast the snl family
welcomed back one of their own
former cast member tracy morgan popped
up in this sketch which highlighted the
awkward nature of men's bathroom combos
well you know what i always say
boss man does what the boss man does
i've never said that in my life
i killed a man in 2012.
and the snl veteran was given the last
laugh
[Applause]
last night and i dropped the ball
and just don't kill my brother
[Music]